en este vídeo vamos a conectar nuestra
cámara digital a nuestra beats y bot
aquí vamos a usar nuestros tornillos
para metal y los colocamos a través del
examen en los agujeros que hicimos
tomamos las pinzas de nariz de aguja y
sostenemos el tornillo usamos el
destornillador para asegurarnos de que
esté bien apretado ahora tomamos algunos
otros de nuestros tornillos y los
colocamos a través de los demás agujeros
que ya habíamos hecho apretamos bien
todos los tornillos para asegurar que
tengamos un buen montaje para nuestra
cámara digital
pueden ver que tenemos colocados los
cuatro tornillos no queremos que la
cámara quede justo encima de el examen
sino que esté un poco elevada y esto es
por dos razones una es para tener un
mejor acceso al puerto usb de la cámara
y la otra es porque la cámara tiene una
pantalla en la parte de atrás que no
queremos que esté encima del excel por
lo que usaremos tuercas para esto y las
pondremos unos 6 milímetros hacia abajo
estas tuercas nos ayudarán a sostener la
cámara encima de el excel la cámara
tiene una pantalla que es sostenida
normalmente por la cubierta pero aquí no
tenemos una así que la mantendremos en
su lugar usando cinta negra aislante
esto evitará que se caiga mientras la
instalamos ponemos la cinta aislante y
cortamos el sobrante con el cúter
estos son los cables de control que
ponemos juntos para que no nos estorben
y podemos ver que la cámara quede bien
colocada
resulta que pega con el anillo de
plástico de bits y bot por lo que vamos
a recortar un poco la tableta pero al
hacerlo tenemos que asegurarnos de no
cortar ninguna ruta o componente del
circuito ahora sí vamos a tratar de
poner en su lugar la tarjeta cuando haga
en este paso en su bits y bot les
recomiendo que antes quiten el arduino
ya que esto les facilitará acomodar sus
cables yo no hice esto porque pensé que
solo bastaría con pasar los cables por
debajo del arduino pero como ven me
llevo bastante tiempo hacer esto además
de que esos cables que usamos en
particular son magnéticos por lo que son
muy delgados y se doblan con facilidad
por lo que es muy laborioso colocarlos
por debajo del arduino es más rápido
quitar las tuercas que sostienen al
arduino para poder quitarlo y acomodar
sin problemas los cables en otro vídeo
termino haciendo esto pero en este lo
hice de la manera difícil
ya tenemos la cámara en su lugar y vamos
a colocar las tuercas encima de los
tornillos para sostener la cámara
después de atornillar la con nuestros
dedos
vamos a usar nuestras pinzas de nariz de
aguja para terminar de atornillar es
importante que hagan esto con cuidado
porque si se les resbala la pinza pueden
quitar o golpear otros componentes como
las resistencias o dañar otros elementos
en la tarjeta así que hay que hacerlo
con calma y es así como colocamos la
cámara y la conectaremos al arduino en
un próximo vídeo